a man turns 18 and signs a contract  he trains for 70 consecutive days he  gets to know every inch of his m16  a4 rifle then he earns the right to be  called  a jar head listen up marines  mission is a goat you'll be extracting a  high value individual from the garmsa  district  her name is anushassan the taliban wants  her dead  washington wants her alive  keep an eye on that ridge look for  snipers  rpg  five of our marines are missing let's  not ride them off they're  supply marines they're marines  we all get scared sometimes it's what  you do when you're under pressure that  matters  short on water short on ammo  and everybody in this province got in  for us  it's not collect  love being a marine hoorah